well this is super exciting thank you so
much for joining me on et Canada pride I
know I am a huge drag fan so something
like CBC gems Queens is really exciting
for me especially at a time like Pride
Month it is a murder mystery whodunit
set in the queer landscape of Toronto
among a bunch of different Queens who
are about to compete for Miss Church
streets you know you can't have a
pageant without a crown I'm the reigning
Miss Church Street is that much like
real drag like in Toronto is there
sabotage that happens to find the scenes
I don't think to this degree for sure I
think the the villain of this show is
certainly going to some extreme lengths
to keep us from performing tell me how
my ellemeet fits into Queens well Naomi
is kind of like a hippie dippie sweet
like loving very like go with the flows
and kind of performer who's a drag queen
who everyone says is really decent but
she doesn't think she has a shot at the
title this year and and then she goes
through a really really intense
transformative experience the day of the
Queen's
yeah mini titty is one of the younger
performers one of the younger Queens but
she has a heart of gold she's really
really eager and I think because she's
so excited and bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed everyone else kind of looks
up her as an eye-roll situation but she
has a few tricks up her sleeve my dad
used to call me a fairy every time I
started acting like myself what's wrong
with a fairy I have you can you mean by
parents you can be every member of my
chosen family as I mentioned on a huge
drag fan I've seen drag all around the
world what I love is how mainstream drag
has become um are you both kind of
constantly surprised to see the
visibility of drag that is out on
screens right now I'm sometimes
surprised to see it but I'm not at all
surprised it's
taking off as a drug then you definitely
know this Stephen is that there's dread
for everyone you know there are a
billion and one different types of drug
and there is something I think
everyone's been finding drag for
themselves and I think it's pretty
incredible the range of performers we
have in the cast which is amazing you
know we have alternative performers that
come from Toronto's West End like myself
and Lucinda we have extremely glamorous
you know pop star diva performers that
have also been in pageants like deta
Hudson
we have trans performers we have
non-binary performers we have a whole
spectrum of different types and
backgrounds of drag performers in the
show which is pretty incredible I have a
lot of friends who were Queens and a lot
of them said being a drag artist has
really saved their lifes essentially
what has drag meant to each of you in
your own lives for myself I am a
full-time costume designer and I went to
theater school for performing and in
school there was always this disconnect
of how can I do both I want to do all
the things that I love instead of you
know having to put time one way or
another and drag has made it so that I
can do everything that I love all at the
same time I came to drag right out of
art school and drag has just become like
the ultimate artistic focus of my life I
could have never thought of I know
especially growing up as a queer person
it is something that really gives you a
unique identity but also a unique input
into the world pride around the world
due to kovat 19 is looking much
different these days but there are ways
that you can still celebrate pride pride
started out as riot right pride started
out thanks to Marsha P Johnson and so we
now have this opportunity to kind of
look inwards and say okay what can i
address in my own self especially
towards racism and anti black racism
what can i address in myself to keep
moving forward and helped the black
trans queer people in our community as
well as in the rest of the world I'm
gonna put you both on the spot right now
Canada's drag race is coming who are you
each rooting for and why all the Queens
that were chosen to be on this first
season
really really incredible and really
represent some amazing parts of Canadian
drag I think the biggest wildcard of the
season is going to be boa I think
everyone getting to see the creative
little dumbass but Boas is just gonna I
think blow people away I ended up sewing
a quite a few outfits for Miss boa and I
can tell me that you are in for a treat
oh hey there if you want more LGBTQ news
and exclusive interviews click Subscribe
or watch these videos